game on presents
the game on intermission break party fun
time
we hope you've been enjoying this
incredible interactive experience
it's been going on for a while now don't
you think you need some kind of a break
you don't want to get burnt out making
all of these very tough decisions do you
don't you feel the weight of the world
pressing down on you the feeling that
whatever you do is never enough
the expectation of the mass is
constantly biting at your heels do you
feel the need to disappear and not talk
to anybody like existence is futile and
nothing really matters
like you are being buried alive
take jacksepticeye for example note the
clear signs of stress in this picture
and in this picture
jacksepticeye is experiencing an extreme
case of excessive feeling of burn to cue
lightness a very common feeling among
youtube gamers
can you identify which of the pictures
jacksepticeye is feeling more burnt to
cue lightness
is it a
or b
[Music]
choose wisely
[Music]
we are keeping score of your choices
[Music]
choose wrong and whose to tell what
might happen
[Music]
good luck
[Music]